I consistently day trade using futures
for just 60 minutes every morning and
I'm able to consistently find profitable
trades. In this video, I'm going to go
through the whole laundry list of things
that you need to know and understand
about futures and how they work. I'm
going to just explain you the basics of
how futures work, how they're priced
differently compared to other assets,
why they're actually just better than
other assets. If you ask me, I've traded
everything and I find futures to be the
best. What's margin? How it works?
What's overnight margin? Intraday
margin, how they're priced, what is the
best place to actually trade futures,
and we'll go through a lot of other
things and even some tax advantages of
trading futures over other assets. And
so, we're going to start with the basics
and slowly build you up. So after the
end of this video, you will be able to
have a trading platform and understand
how futures work and to be able to start
executing a trading strategy with it.
Now, futures work differently than
stocks in many ways, but once you
understand them, it's very simple. Just
like trading a normal stock, if you buy
it and it goes up, you make money. And
if it goes down, you lose money. For
example, though, the big difference is
when you buy, let's say, one share of
Apple, you can hold that share as long
as you want. You own a piece of that
company and it will never expire unless
the company goes bankrupt or is taken
private. With futures, you aren't
actually buying part of, let's say, a
company like Apple. You are buying a
contract agreement that's value is based
on the market it's connected with. So
for example, let's say you buy one
futures contract in the oil market. The
contract's value will go up when the oil
price increases and it will go down if
the price decreases. The exact same way
a share price of Apple would go up or
down. So when it comes to the
practicality of actually trading this,
there's basically no difference. But the
only thing is the futures contracts
expire unlike shares. The length of a
futures contract can depend on what
market you're actually trading, but
generally it's one month or three month.
This is the one reason why futures are
shorter term trading asset. It's not
something you hold for a long term. Most
people like me day trade using them.
That's where the real advantage comes
into play. The trading platform I'm
using is called Ninja Trader. I've been
using them for over 5 years now. And one
of the nice things is they don't charge
you to practice with live trading data
right away, which most platforms do. You
can check it out using the link in the
description of this video or using this
QR code. Now, technically, when you buy
an oil futures contract, you are buying
the ability to buy a,000 barrels of oil
at a certain price. That's the nuts and
bolts behind it. But in reality, you're
never going to do that. You were just
using this contract to get leverage of
a,000 barrels of oil because this
contract actually costs a fraction of
the purchase price of 1,000 barrels of
oil. But you get the value increase or
decrease of those,000 barrels of oil.
It's the exact same thing as buying a
house with a loan. You only put up the
down payment for the house, let's say
$100,000 on a million-doll house, but
you get the increase or decrease of the
milliondoll value of the house, but
you're only putting up a fraction of the
total value in the down payment. Now, in
the trading world, that down payment on
the house is not called a down payment.
It's called a margin requirement. Just
think of it like the collateral that you
need to put up for one futures contract
of let's say oil. For example, now if we
buy one futures contract of the SNP500
futures, which is a different futures
market, this will take about $500 worth
of margin. Your account will have $500
taken away as collateral. But when you
sell the contract back, you get the $500
worth of margin back. Now, this isn't
taking into account the profit or loss
that you made on the specific trade you
took. So, when you see the price of the
S&P 500 futures trading at, let's say,
6,000, it doesn't actually cost you
$6,000 to buy one futures contract
compared to, you know, when you buy
shares. It's actually based on the
margin requirement at the time. Now the
market requirement will differ from
asset to asset like oil futures to wheat
futures or from brokerage to brokerage
and time of day. And so let me break
down to you each one of those
categories. First off, you have what is
called intraday and overnight margin.
So, for example, the US stock market is
only open during the New York trading
session, which is 9:30 a.m. Eastern
Standard Time till 4:00 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time. This is the only time of
day that you can trade stocks that are
in that market. But futures, on the
other hand, are open almost 24 hours a
day, 7 days a week. They technically
close for a short amount of time after
the New York session closes. and over
the weekend. But this is how the
intraday and overnight margin difference
is made. If you're trading, let's say,
the S&P 500 futures during the New York
session when all other stocks are open
in that 9:30 to 4:00 window, you only
are required to put up the intraday
margin, which is generally extremely low
compared to the overnight margin, which
is anytime the New York market is
closed. So, for the S&P 500 futures and
really any US-based futures, it's going
to cost you a lot more to trade outside
of that stock market open window. Now,
these margin requirements can change
based on brokerage. Some of the
brokerage have the more normal margin
requirements, which can be roughly 5 to
7,000 for the intraday. But other ones
like Ninja Trader, which is the one I
use, can have low margin requirements
for, let's say, the S&P 500 futures. One
contract can be $500 worth of margin,
which is tiny for how much leverage and
potential and profit that it gives you.
But for almost all the platforms, the
overnight margin is never reduced, which
is generally double the intraday margin
or around 15,000 for the S&P 500
futures. Now these are the normal margin
numbers. This can actually change when
market volatility goes up because when
the market goes crazy, brokerages will
see that there is more risk and so
they'll ask for more collateral
basically. So for example, in the CO
2020 market crash, the margin
requirements were double or triple at
times, but it only happens very rarely
in extreme times like this. And so it
doesn't need to be something that you're
super aware of. And generally you should
have enough money in your account to
cover the change. Now, another minor
difference between futures contracts is
you have ones like oil where you're
gaining control over a physical asset.
And if you held that physical asset
contract to expiration and used it, you
would get barrels of oil. On other ones
like the S&P 500 futures or NASDAQ
futures, they aren't actually based on a
physical product. It's actually based on
the index that follows. So, these ones
are just settled in cash. But if you're
day trading or even just holding them
over a couple of nights, you don't need
to be worried about having to deal with
settling the contracts because it's
basically never happens. I've never had
this happen to me because I always close
them out or what we'll talk about in a
minute is roll them over to the next
expiration. You would actually have to
hold it until the last week of
expiration and hold it probably through
the date of it expiring for that to have
to happen. But the brokerages and
platforms will usually just close you
out of the trade as well before you have
to do something like that just because
it's a nightmare on their end as well.
And I'm sure you don't want to have uh
you know a thousand barrels of oil
showing up at your front door. And
whenever it really gets close to that
date, you always trade the new contract
anyway. You'll even do it a couple weeks
beforehand. And what this is called is
it's called a rollover. And on Ninja
Trader and other platforms, you
generally don't have to worry about it.
The system will either update or send
you a message that pops up and tells you
to roll over to the next contract.
Generally, I always do it a week before
because that's most of the time that
I've noticed is when the volume picks up
on the next contract anyway. And you
always want to be trading the contract
with the most volume. And all this means
is like a Ninja Trader, you are changing
the ticker symbol, which is technically
the contract expiration, to the next
one. So to walk you through what this
looks like, the S&P 500 futures expires
every 3 months and it's always the same
month. Essentially, it starts at the new
year and it does it every quarter of the
year. And the expiration week will
always be on the Friday of the third
week of that expiration month. So, if
you have an expiration of, let's say,
3:25, this means it's the third month of
the year 2024 and then it will always
default to expiring the third Friday of
the month. And all you need to do is it
depends on the platform, but at least on
Ninja Trader, you'll generally just
click the rollover button, but you can
also just change in the ticker to just
saying 624 cuz all you're changing is
you're just moving over to the next
month. Now, some platforms will actually
just have letters for the month instead.
You can see right here, this is what the
letter corresponds with the month, and
it will always be the same for every
futures contract, no matter what you're
trading. But remember, some will do it
every 3 months, and some will do it
every month. Now, when it comes to
trading, that $500 worth of margin for
one S&P 500 futures contract is still
massive for a small account. And so if
you're wanting to start with an account
of let's say $500 or $1,000, what you
can do is you can trade what is called
the micro futures. All the main futures
contracts have them and they're
essentially onetenth of the size of the
normal contract size. So for the S&P 500
futures, which are normally $500 margin
to purchase, the micro version is only
$50, but also the price movement is
onetenth of the size as well. So, your
trades are going to be smaller. But what
this does is it allows you, and it's a
super simple way to start and grow your
small account. I did the exact same
thing with my account. I started trading
the S&P 500 futures with micro futures,
risking $50 to $100 per trade, and then
I slowly traded, growing that account,
and I increased that trading size more
and more. and then I eventually switched
to the normal future size of the S&P 500
futures when my account was big enough.
Now, the other important thing about
futures is understanding how the
movement in price relates to dollar
change in your trade. For shares, it's
super simple because their share value
is based off of a dollar value. If your
share of Apple goes up $1, you make $1.
its value is based on the dollar change.
Now, with futures, it's completely
different. First, the price movement
isn't based on money. So, if you're
looking at the S&P 500 futures and you
have one S&P 500 contract that goes
from, let's say, $6,000 to 6,01, that
doesn't mean your contract value goes up
$1. It actually goes up $50. And this is
called one point. The movement from
5,000 to 50,0001 is called one point.
Think of it just as a numerical change
of one. Now, going back to shares, the
smallest amount they can move is one
penny, but that isn't the smallest
amount the S&P 500 futures move. The
smallest amount of movement is
0.25, which is called one tick. It's 1/4
of a point. So, it's valued at
$12.50. Now, this point value and tick
size is different for each futures
market. So, for the ES futures, which is
the S&P 500, it's smallest tick size is
0.25 and that's valued at $12.50. And
the point value is $50. But if we go
look at oil, the smallest amount of
movement it can do is
0.01, or almost you could say like a
penny. And that's called a tick for oil.
That's the smallest movement it can do.
and that's valued at $10 a tick. So, one
point or one numerical movement in oil
is valued at
$1,000, but there's way more ticks and
movements in that one point of movement.
And so, if you look at the two markets,
the amount that they move is drastically
different. Oil moves in a lot smaller
increments. So, the sizing of the
contract value with $1,000 for a point
makes sense because it's generally only
moving between $60 to $80 and you know
the S&P 500 futures which is valued you
know between 5,000 and 6,000 has a lot
more point movement in between there.
Now, one thing to be aware of is trading
futures. You are overleveraging
yourself. For the ES futures contract,
only putting up $500 worth of margin
isn't your max loss. Technically, you
own one contract of the ES futures
market. And if the market suddenly
crashes, you could lose more than your
account or that $500. Now, this almost
never happens. I've never had it happen
to me over the, you know, five plus
years I've been trading futures. And
there's a couple ways you can protect
yourself to make sure this doesn't ever
happen. The first way is always have a
stop-loss in place no matter what. Never
move it farther away. First off,
increasing your potential risk once
you're in a trade because if the market
opens and goes against you really
quickly, this stop-loss will get you out
of the trade as fast as possible, not
allowing you to lose more than you were
planning. Now, you can get something
called slippage, where the market's
moving so fast, even a market order
won't get filled at the exact price.
This doesn't really happen that often,
and in the end, it's not actually that
much money that it will slip. You might
lose a bit more than you wanted to, but
it won't be a crazy amount. The other
way for this to happen, and let me show
you on a chart real quick, is if you
traded and held through the futures
market, closing and then opening. And so
essentially what that would look like is
if you entered in let's say a buy here
expecting the market's going to go up
and the futures market closes for an
hour after the trading day every day.
And so you can see here if you entered
in a trade here, the market closed right
at this price and then opened all the
way down here. And if your stop loss of
let's say risking $500 was right here.
And let's say your account, you know, is
$1,000 and you're only planning to risk
a couple hundred here. Well, the best
price you could have done was all the
way down here, which would have been a
couple thousand dollar worth of loss.
And so that's how you could have had an
overexaggerated amount of loss that
could theoretically blow your account
up. So that's the biggest thing that I
would do is never hold futures into an
overnight close or even over into the
weekend when it closes. Basically, when
it closes and opens again, that's your
big window for having an extreme loss
that you can't get out of. And also,
this happens a lot because news or you
know, stock earnings will come out right
after the market closes. And so when it
opens again and you know, let's say
Apple comes out with a really bad
earnings report because Apple's a big
part of let's say the S&P 500 futures or
if you're trading the NASDAQ futures,
it'll make a big drop and a gap like
that we saw in the futures contract that
you're trading and you'll take a massive
loss. Lastly, the only fees that come
with trading futures is generally kind
of some kind of routing fee and then the
commissions that the trading brokerage
you use. Generally, the routing or
trading fees are fixed and will be same
across the board. And then futures
commissions are based on the brokers
that you're using, but because there's
so many big platforms out there and
they're all super competitive on the
commissions, you're not really going to
find much of a difference throughout
them. There's also no interest or fees
with the margin that you use. That's for
different types of margin accounts.
generally trading like stocks on margin.
Also, don't get confused with other
types of margin in trading and investing
that can have interest rates on the
margin that you use. That's when you're
essentially taking a loan out for this.
The margin is more of again, think of
that like collateral or down payment
you're using. And so, really cool about
futures is the tax benefits that comes
with it. Now, I mainly switched to
futures because of the simplicity. It's
exactly like trading stocks, and it's
not complicated like options, but it
gives you the leverage that options
allow. So, it's kind of the best of both
worlds. You know, you buy it, it goes
up, you make money, and you can do it
with a small account and get super crazy
leverage. And then as well, on the back
end, when it comes to tax season,
there's a really cool rule that is
applied to it. Now, of course, I'm not a
tax professional. This is kind of just
what I know from doing it myself and
kind of on and what's out there just
based on the internet. And so when it
comes down to it, 60% of your profits is
in a way lower tax bracket and then 40%
is in your normal tax bracket. You know,
what you make in that year as a normal
like let's say W2. And so what this
allows you to do is even though you're
day trading, it counts in a way as a
long-term investment or asset. and you
essentially just get to keep more of the
money you made compared to everything
else. You have to hold it for a whole
year before it becomes in that long-term
capital gains category. And so now let's
go to Ninja Trader here and I'm going to
practically show you some of how this
looks like on a real chart. And so this
is looking at the S&P 500 futures, the
ES futures. We're looking at the main
contract, not the micro smaller version.
This is the full contract. And you can
see over here on the left side is this
is the price movement and it's going up
in
0.25 increments. Sometimes it might jump
a little bit more because the market's
moving pretty quickly right now, but
generally it'll move up by 0.25. And
then if I just click right here, buy
market at one contract, you can see that
the dollar amount is going up or down in
12.25 25 increments. And if it moves up
one point in my favor, that'll be about
$50. And so you can see just looking at
we're looking at a one minute chart
right here. The dollar movement per
price is very, very large. We're trading
one contract here. And you can see over
this one small candlestick, I'm already
up like $200. And so you can imagine if
the market just moves up right here,
that's probably like $1,000. And this
move right here that took about 25
minutes with one futures contract would
have been probably like $2,000. And so
you can see the leverage of that money
comes into play massively. You know,
this costed me $500 worth of margin. And
you can see that I'm already basically
up $500. And so the leverage there that
you can get on a tiny account to
potentially make a a huge amount is
really really big with these contracts.
But again, you can see on the flip side
that $500 I was up has all of a sudden
seemed to start to evaporate, right? And
so again, leverage can work against you
or for you. And so that's where you want
to then go into. If I then just, you
know, this is just a demo account. I'm
not going to just be goofing around on
real money here. Um, if we go into the
micro futures, you can see it looks the
exact same chart, but if I buy one
contract now, it's a tenth of the size.
It's going up or down, a
$125. And so, this is the exact same
thing for everything in terms of if you
jump into a micro futures contract, it
allows you to now start with a super
small account. And these movements for a
small account are a lot more manageable.
you know, instead of risking, you know,
$500 for a small swing, which can seem
huge, I could put, you know, enter in
here and put my stop loss down here and
I could be risking $20 and I could, you
know, my target could be $30. And so,
this is how you can start with a really,
really small account and then slowly
scale because then, of course, to scale
up, it's super easy to say, well,
instead of buying one contract, I now
want to buy two contracts. And you know,
see here it's number two means how many
contracts I have. And now it's going up
by, you know, $2.50 instead of a$125 per
tick because I have two contracts
instead of one. And so you can, you
know, that's how you it's allowed you
can you can easily increment your size
as you go up. And so you can see this
movement here is, you know, now I can
target maybe $200 worth of profit for,
you know, a $50 or $75 risk as you
slowly increase your size when you're
becoming profitable. And so the best way
that I have actually found to trade
futures is actually looking for
reversals on a one minute chart. You can
trade futures on a 1 minute, a 5 minute,
or even an hourly chart. Again, it's all
about try not to hold through overnight
and mainly just sticking to day trading.
That's really where the power comes in.
You can hold something for a couple
days, but again, it opens you up to that
risk of having, you know, those large
drops from, you know, the market closing
and then opening up again with news in
between. But what I found to be super
powerful is literally in the first 60
minutes every morning, I just watch the
US stock market open. That's when it it
super volatile, has a lot of potential
swings like this. And you can see this
swing right here in the last, you know,
what we were just looking at, that could
be a couple thousand, right? If you're
trading large size and so you can easily
make a strong amount of money trading
once you become profitable with this
strategy in literally just 60 minutes in
a day. It's what I have traded for a
while now and it's literally all I do.
And so to walk you through that now what
I do every morning I literally just come
in I look for key areas of you know
support and resistance and you can see
here the market bounced right here and
so that's why I'm kind of thinking okay
well if it comes down here again I want
to see if we'll bounce again and so
that's kind of the first thing that I
always look for in this strategy is
looking for the market to bounce at a
key level. You don't want to just be
randomly thinking, okay, well, it'll go
here, it'll go there. You know, that's
when you start to become reactionary to
the market and you want to actually have
a plan and wait for the market to fit
that plan. I have realized that over
time that that's really the way to
become profitable. And the other part of
that is just find one strategy and one
pattern that works. You don't need to
find 10 different strategies and be
trying to capture, you know, every move
in the market because like you just saw
when it comes to the sizing and scaling
these numbers in a way can become
infinitely huge, right? You could be
literally risking $10,000 on a trade and
make, you know,
$40,000 in 20 minutes. Now, that seems
mindblowing because, you know, when I
first started, I was risking literally
like $25, $50, but now in this trade
right here, I'm risking something like
$500. And you'll see the potential can
go really fast once you kind of get this
in play. And so, the next thing I like
to look for is, you can see the market
came down here to this level and it
actually broke this downtrend. So,
that's kind of the second thing I like
to look for when you're looking for
reversals. you need to make sure that
the downtrend is broken. And so what
I've done here is I've kind of confirmed
that after this trend was broken. And so
it's starting to show some strength,
some bullish candlesticks. And I like
that for getting in on a trade, betting
that the market is going to go higher.
Now, kind of the last couple thing I
like to look for is I want to see the
market kind of start to show kind of a
bottoming pattern. Right here, it's
basically making higher highs. And so I
like this as this candlestick was a
really kind of a big bearish candlestick
attempting the market to go lower and it
failed here based on these candlesticks.
And so I like the idea of saying, "Hey,
I want to get in long above this
candlestick right here betting that the
market is going to go higher." And so I
put what is called a buy stop order
above it. If the price of the market
touches this price, put in a market
order. I don't care where you feel me
at. Just get me in the market. And most
of the time you can see it literally
just filled at that exact price. But
sometimes it can, you know, fill you
right here because the market can move
pretty fast. But that is the order I
like to enter in on most of the time.
And you know, you can use a buy limit
order that will get you in below or
exactly at that price. But the problem
with that is well for this example right
here well the market kind of took off
here and you would have felt a lot of
FOMO and you would have because you
would have missed out on the trade and
you would have had to wait for and hope
that the market comes back down and
fills you at that price. And so you can
see here quickly just over a couple
candlesticks I'm already up $1,000 on
this trade risking you know I think $500
or $600. And so this is where the power
comes into play is I'm trading four oil
futures contracts here. And you can see
it's moving in that
0.01 increment, that penny size,
compared to the S&P 500 futures that
we're just looking at was actually
moving in that quarter of a point size,
that 0.25. But you can see here clearly
that the money is a lot more. And so for
me, my strategy is I like to kind of get
in when I see, you know, basically you
can easily see here is there's a lot of
momentum here. It started to slow down
by essentially just seeing that the
market kind of started chop here. And
then I look for a couple few key factors
to jump in and catch the momentum to the
other side. And so I moved my stop here
to break even. And then as this starts
to kind of get pretty accelerated here,
I like to use kind of the idea that,
hey, okay, I'm gonna give it a little
bit of wiggle room, but I'm going to
move my stop up if it pulls back
because, you know, I'm up about $2,000.
And, you know, you want to let this
thing run if it's going to run, but you
also, you know, you can see like just as
it pulled back right here, it can
reverse very, very quickly, too. And so,
that's where I really look to, you know,
manage my trades. But again, that's come
with a lot of practice and experience
trading this. You know, my target here,
you can see now that we're getting up to
here. You can see we're kind of in a
support level that I've drawn from
previously in the chart. And that's
where I'm going to expect things to slow
down. And so, you can see I've moved my
stop loss up here. It's, you know, we're
up a lot more money now. And this is
where kind of the power comes into play
of using technical analysis with futures
is you have that leverage and you have
that ease of getting in and out of the
market, but you also have the simplicity
of, you know, you're not having to deal
with the complexity of options and other
factors that come into play with other
assets. And so to just to close this
out, you know, I'm not going to go into
my strategy too much here. I have a lot
more videos on that, but I pretty much
get knocked out right there. So, no
matter how you're planning to start
trading, even if you're planning to
start prop firm trading, I highly
recommend demo trading first. The fees
for prop firm trading can be really
expensive if you're not able to be
consistently profitable right away.
That's why it's smart to use Ninja
Trader first and once you're more
comfortable, then switch over to prop
firms. Again, you can check out Ninja
Trader in the description or using this
QR code. And if you want to just learn
more about my strategy I've been talking
about here, check out this video right
here.